so we've been talking quite a bit about
HR 676 this proposal from Democrats in
the house back from January which would
potentially expand Medicare Medicare for
all
Kyle kolinsky over its secular talk
recently talked about the fact that a
recent poll shows support for Medicare
for all has once again hit a record high
let's check out what Kyle had to say
about it
Talking Points Memo is reporting on a
brand new healthcare poll that just came
out they say a new poll suggests the
country may be shifting left on the
issue of health care with 62% saying is
the federal government's responsibility
to make sure that all Americans have
health care coverage while 37% say it's
not the survey findings from The
Associated Press n o RC Center for
Public Affairs Research indicate a
change in public attitudes over the past
few months as concerns mounted about GOP
legislation estimated to leave tens of
millions without coverage so that's a
record I've never seen a number that
high 62% of the country now says it's
the federal government's responsibility
to make sure that all Americans have
health care coverage and that framing is
actually harder to get the higher number
than if you were to say Medicare for all
if you just say Medicare for all it
would be even higher at this point
because saying it's the federal
government's responsibility to make sure
they have it people tend to go oh that
means big government I don't know if I'm
in favor of that but if you say Medicare
for all they get a higher number so we
got 62 percent when they framed the
question in a way that wasn't even
favorable to answering yes to put that
in perspective for you the same poll in
March just 52 percent now we're still a
majority even then but we're talking an
increase in 10 percentage points in that
short time span
whoa man whoa and what's the difference
what's the difference stop and think
about it well we have Bernie Sanders
who's been busting his ass since the
second he really burst onto the national
scene and that really gained the
notoriety I mean letting everybody know
about the concept of Medicare for all
and how every other nation has
version or another of a single-payer
system so you know we're getting screwed
there's Bernie Sanders doing that and
then there's what you guys there's
National Nurses United there's brand new
Congress there's justice Democrats
there's the Green Party there's
Democratic socialists there's populace
left progressive activists who've said
I've had enough I've had enough I'm done
with the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
compromise on things that aren't even
debatable haha from the Democrats no but
we're this is a non-negotiable Medicare
for all that's not negotiable that's one
of the core fundamental bedrock policies
and principles of somebody who's
supposed to be on the left so the other
angle here that's really important is
anytime we see a poll it's really
important to go and look at the
methodology right because when it comes
to for example the government providing
some basic level of health health care
health coverage for everybody if you
look at one poll where the headline
might be most people don't want
government involved in health care and
you look at another poll which says
two-thirds of Americans want the
government involved in health care you
might say how is this possible and with
that particular instance we went and
looked at the polls and there's no
question if you say to people do you
support a communistic government
takeover of health insurance you're
going to get more people that say that
doesn't sound good I don't want that
definitely not on the other hand if you
say to people does the US government
have a responsibility to provide some
basic level of coverage to every
American regardless of ability to pay
which is really what you're talking
about when you think about the
government getting more involved in
health care you get two-thirds or even
more of Americans saying yes and that's
why when we when we go by and this
applies to science reporting as well
when we go by the headlines were usually
screwing ourselves in terms of really
understanding what it is that's going on
and when it comes to science reporting
we've talked many times the write-ups
about that latest cancer drug
or treatment study or whatever are very
often not representative of what's in
the study and I always say to people
read the abstract at minimum if you
don't have the time or interest in going
through the minutiae of the actual
studies don't fall just for the
headlines and it's part of what being an
informed news consumer is now as far as
the specifics of the medicare-for-all
support i've been saying for weeks if
not months that democrats need to fully
get it together and say we want medicare
for all or single-payer or whatever even
if you think it's unlikely to happen and
you would be right to think it's
unlikely to happen with a Republican
White House House and Senate the
Democrats have been taking these
lukewarm positions to start with and end
up negotiating to really conservative
policy the Affordable Care Act Obamacare
being a great example of that even if
you don't really think you're going to
get it in the next three and a half
years which you're not take the position
take the actual position that you
support and that's where we get the sort
of the status thing which is there's a
lot of corporate Democrats who genuinely
don't want Medicare for all and that's a
bigger problem that we've talked about
and we'll continue to talk about